this is amazing already on the map Sue's
Lee Oh egg menu is still there too
nothing is going the game with the best
guys wait up
seriously you're standing still on the
mat mark yeah I see everyone else is
doing [ __ ] really yeah this game is
really buggy alright so you start it if
you can maybe we should do that yeah no
it's not the real world
I went right in the beginning don't you
I think my game is completely what anal
ball where are you going
it's like winning too much for me again
come on [ __ ] came how do you get
sponsorships I was number one until the
water oh my god where's my son
I'm on the track now it's fine I was so
[ __ ] hard for my sponsorship and this
you're flying right in front of me I
don't know I don't know got a pulling up
I got what's happening I don't know
which is rings to go in oh man I knit I
didn't appreciate this song until now
France yeah it's like really hardcore if
someone could actually win that would be
great um I should be finishing well lap
two of two but yeah oh god oh my god
mother [ __ ] right behind me help me
sponsorship that sponsorships finish you
want good job good job good job you did
it I would say it says I wonder no wait
is it I'm still going I'm still going is
it supersonic all right I'm supersonic
now race now I wouldn't [ __ ] that I want
sponsorship really just flying like an
idiot and I am at like I don't even know
how you didn't win cuz you were in front
of me I think whoa [ __ ] Skrillex is
playing in the background oh I keep
flying in the [ __ ] there's like dent in
the ground that like makes me fly wait
go down it's a trick oh my god its trick
he's so beautiful
Oh overlord strike a letter organoid oh
my god Jesus I'm stuck by our older boy
you got freaking oh my god I have to
obey my ogre Lord from Ally
sorry let you know trap my bad I decide
to let go call them here
I miss my mission Mount Everest truck Oh
God
oh there's Ken did you hear that oh I
got like sanic music plating likes oh oh
who would have thought like I'm making
bowls as sanic was a good idea you're
all gonna be big balls [ __ ] you yeah we
got we got big man oh Jesus what
happened ready up [ __ ]
whoa we're so nicely scrubs No
oh god I'm up the map I'm off the map
now the mountain yeah I got [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Oh God oh Jesus
oh I gotta hit the ceiling I've got what
an ugly [ __ ] guys say guys so gonna
copyright this say say yeah it's just
like why did we not think of that sanic
it's Bowl really better than any game
Sega's made in the last decade yeah you
missed a checkpoint you missed a
checkpoint
I think whoa mother [ __ ] is coming he's
beating us in a lap really bad I'll hug
you mark I'll hit you
[Music]
let's help mark it's really hard that
put him off the map should we should we
should we change the game that actually
works
Brett ChaCha's I hope you enjoyed this
episode we had a lot of fun playing so
thank you for hanging alike
was that a sentence things would look
like thank you for hitting it like
that's all for me for now
mwah stay awesome bros bro fears